if I'm to say an angry song people
automatically are like what's going on
in your personal life thinking my
marriage is falling apart or something
you know I'm it's just that there's own
personal barriers that I think I put up
in the past so in in an attempt to
remedy that I channeled her meat n
lights fictional alter ego and
inspiration for the sudras fourth studio
album skin and earth
[Music]
the conceptual record coincides with the
release of lights first-ever comic-book
series which follows end through a
dystopian universe and made the 30 year
old singer expand her skill set as an
artist I did all in it I wrote it
through it lettered it and delivered it
I have been doing this Connick 100%
needs me in this format needs to be
these specs you know I don't know I
learned what I can learn my music okay
with so many comics making the leap from
the pages to the big screen fans are
wondering if flights would ever make the
jump to acting the audition for all
kinds of shows throughout the course of
all these years and never got parts a
case in point years and years ago I
auditioned for the part on instant star
for instance I came out and never got
part but then fast forward to season
four I'm writing songs for it so
everything in the world comes full
circle I think it's good to branch out
into different art forms mine probably
isn't gonna be acting but maybe comics
maybe something else in the meantime
lights is gearing up for her upcoming
fall tour and tells us for a
three-year-old daughter Rock it will be
along for the ride even if it makes
things a little more complicated one
thing I really learned since becoming a
parent is like you have to roll with the
punches you have to allow spontaneity
into your life I used to be very like
paranoid by change and it's not if plans
would change I'd be like spongebob
cavemen
I mean I've learned to roll with it a
little bit more and I've been liberated
I think because of it